let's talk about something not as upbeat
as that
something even more disconcerting and
that is what's happening at the border
it is a mess we've told you that the
administration won't call it a crisis
kamala harris has been put in charge of
trying to figure out the root causes why
all those people from central america
come here
we know why because it's easy to get
across the border nonetheless
there she was doing a zoom call at the
washington conference on the americas
and listen to some of the world leaders
she's talking to
about the root causes and what they can
do to help
us this is a priority for our nation
and a role that i take very seriously
the citizens of el salvador guatemala
honduras are leaving their homes at
alarming rates
they are suffering they are in pain many
are experiencing
[Music]
anguish and so we are focused on
addressing
both the acute factors and the root
causes
of migration i believe this is an
important distinction
we must focus on both i've also spoken
with world leaders from canada finland
ireland
japan about partnering with us to help
the northern triangle please ireland
stop sitting back
finland we're asking you to help it's
obviously something's right on finland's
mind
worried about the central america and
why wouldn't they be by the way finland
was voted the happiest
country in the world so the plan is a
four billion dollar plan
and she announced a 310 million dollar
investment
in that region she says she wants to go
to honduras and deliver food shelter
water to the people guatemala she wants
to work with the farmers to plant
drought resistant crops and help women
farmers increase their crops
what about our crops what about our
homeless sure well this is a crisis as
we all know
and apparently one of the plans is to
send spend
4 billion fantastic so how much money
are we going to send down to those
countries because we know how it works
extortion the more money we
send down there you know okay we're
gonna send you four billion dollars
stop the people from coming if they stop
the people from coming
then we would stop sending them the
money so do you really think that's
going to address the root cause
and stop people from coming not a chance
no problem it goes back to trump these
are trump's policies that are
giving us so much of a challenge or a
crisis down at the border
no one's buying that